- Well everything's better
with a little curly spoon.
Whoa, I need another one.
- [Voiceover] What are some things
you think you're gonna be trying today?
- I feel like it would be something
that wouldn't have to be refrigerated.
- Probably be eating some
sort of like plankton.
- Tasty, sustainable stuff.
(techno music)
- I don't know, it just
looks like buttered toast.
- I knew it was mayo right away.
So I guess that's a good thing.
- Vegan, vegan mayo.
Does that mean all future foods are vegan?
Does that mean all vegans
are from the future?
- Oh, why's it so?
- I'm flippin' this upside-down.
This is goin' straight on the tongue.
- It's great, I would buy this.
- Look, I'm not the biggest mayo guy,
but that's from the future.
(techno music)
- I'm gonna tell myself
this is a chicken nugget
'cause it looks like a chicken nugget.
- This is, this is science food.
- Well, they look like ghosts in motion.
- Is it plant based?
We'll find out.
- You could totally trick kids
and tell them these are chicken nuggets
and they'd believe you.
- It's cardboard ground up deep-fried.
- Mmm, I think it's real meat.
- You cares if it's actually chicken.
It's better for you and you can like
trick your brain, trick your brain.
(techno music)
- Oh god, it's gonna be soylent.
- It happens to be soylent.
- It looks like android blood from
the Alien franchise.
- Oh.
- Oh my god.
- This is like what an alien would make
if they've never seen food.
- It's like somebody
ground up a bunch of wheat,
added water and said,
"Here ya go, nutrients."
- What the hell is that?
- It's not that bad,
it's just not that good.
- [Voiceover] In what scenario would
you willingly drink soylent?
- When there's only soylent.
(techno music)
- Oh no, they're pancakes.
- This looks like some
kind of meat pancake.
- I had maple syrup in my car
in case of pancake emergencies.
- Ugh, they probably have
like cricket butts in them.
- [Voiceover] Very
good, it's cricket flour
instead of regular all-purpose flour.
- Really, it's cricket flour?
- [Voiceover] That's correct.
- Nailed it.
- Oh god, it's just like so gritty.
- Like the animal, like the insect?
- That is a tasty future right there.
I love it.
(techno music)
- It's got like a weird sweet smell to it.
- I hope this is made out
of like old Starbursts.
- Can I eat this cup?
- Oh, it's so hard.
- It's like a Fruit Roll-Up.
- Wouldn't this be fun for like kids.
- They should just make a
whole line of kitchen utensils.
- If I had to drink soylent,
I wanna drink it out of this.
- They were all kind
of a little bit weird.
- I like the idea of the soylent best.
Just, it just makes sense and I feel like
it's something I'd try just to see
if it would be beneficial to my health.
- Future food, dig it.
- [Voiceover] So I think
we just need more like
people goin' through
fields and eatin' plants
and seein' which ones taste
like mayonnaise or cheeseburgers.
- Be careful, lots of plants are toxic.
- It's just so sad what's
happening over there.
- Oh yeah.
You don't know the half of it.
(lighthearted music)